hey everyone dear volume here and in
today's video we're going to be going
over one of tokyo revenge's most loyal
characters and the best friend of
kazutori hanamiya
the man i'm talking about is no one
other than the goat himself kesuki baji
but before we get into baji make sure
you hit that subscribe button to keep up
to date with the latest tokyo revenges
reviews
spoilers and more and also leave a like
on the video if you do enjoy my content
as it really helps out with the
algorithm and pushes my content to a
bunch of new amazing people
but enough of that let's get into the
video parchin
mitsuya drakken mikey
kazatora toman's founding members are my
treasure i wanted to fix this on my own
but i couldn't i died on my own this
quote here from bhaji
is probably one of the most impactful of
the series affecting the outcome of the
entire valhalla arc and i think it
perfectly goes to show who kesuki baji
really is as a person baji is a founding
member of tomen
along with the five previously mentioned
names and is the main reason for the
creation of the group in the first place
as he was constantly getting roughed up
by a group of people living around his
area
because of this mikey decided to start
the tokyo manji gang and protect baji so
that he would be able to get home
safely baji is 15 years of age at the
start of the series and is introduced as
the captain of the tokyo manche gang's
first division
as a child baji was extremely close
friends with mikey and they would often
have mock fights in their favorite
meeting place which was called the
jungle gym
in the same place both bhaji and mikey
came up with the idea of calling each
other foreign names so that emma would
feel less left out as she was the only
one with a western name
on this day the invincible mikey was
created along with bhaji choosing the
gaijin name of edward which suits his
other nickname of point dexter what
shifu you gave him after they first met
in school it's like both names point to
baji being somewhat smart when in all
reality baji was extremely dull and was
held back a few years
baji has an extremely wild personality
matching his stunning long jet black
hair that he either wears left
free-flowing or tied up into a ponytail
while he is fighting or doing something
strenuous
when young baji and kazutori decided to
break into a local bike shop and steal
mikey's dream bike due to mikey
constantly being the butt of other
gang's jokes
as they would laugh when they saw him
driving around on a moped unknowingly
baji and kazutora broke into the
motorbike shop that just happened to be
owned by
sano shinchero better known as mikey's
older brother and the creator of the
first generation black dragons
after mikey's brother caught them and
was about to confront them kazutora hit
him over the back of the head
instantly killing him not realising who
he was this resulted in both baji and
kezitora being sentenced to time in
juvenile prison
although bhaji ends up spending a lot
less time there than kazutori does he
also tries his best to get mikey to
forgive kazatura for the mistake both of
them have made
after first meeting baji in the series
he abruptly ended up leaving tomen and
decided to join the new rival gang
valhalla for a completely unknown reason
at the time to takamichi and the other
tomen members this unknown reason is
later revealed through baji's first
division vice captain
and close friend shifuyu matsuno it is
said that bhaji is actually infiltrating
valhalla to find out more information
on the dangerous kisaki teter and to try
and save another original tomin member
kazutura hanamiya from falling
completely into darkness
although baji may not be mentally smart
like hisaki he is extremely perceptive
and was able to figure out who was truly
threatening tomin being the only other
one aside from takamichi who realizes so
this just goes to show how well he can
judge someone of how they look
and act in fact bhaji's acting skills as
well even for
the entirety of tomen and valhalla he
goes as far as beating shifuyu
in front of everyone to show that he has
just physically cut ties with everyone
at tomin and is able to fool kazatura
kisaki and hanma
along with the other leaders of valhalla
into believing that he had rarely cut
ties with the tokyo manji gang
baji is probably tommen's third
strongest member behind mikey and drakon
he was able to hold his own against a
bunch of insanely strong opponents
and was able to endure fighting past 50
odd enemies with a stab wound and just a
metal pole as a weapon
on the night that valhalla finally verse
toeman baji was stabbed in the back by
kazutora who was enraged and couldn't
hold himself back from his murderous
intent after finding out bhaji's true
intentions the stab wasn't immediately
fatal and like i said just before
he was able to fight his way through 50
odd enemies before he fainted due to the
huge amount of blood loss
appearing dead to mikey it drove sano
completely over the edge who took out
all of his anger of kazutora who is
completely defenseless against the rage
of mikey before things could escalate to
the point of mikey beating kazutura to
death baji rises back
up and screams for mikey he thanks mikey
for getting mad on his behalf as any
true friend would and while getting up
and walking towards him says that
kazutoro's stab wound would not kill him
instead he opens up his own switchblade
and stabs himself in the gut
kazutoro also rises back up and affirms
that he will die along with bhaji
and mikey says that he will beat him to
death even more enraged at the sight of
bhaji dying
takamichi completely stunned on how
things have turned out here
asks what bhaji wanted to achieve by
stabbing himself
bhaji tells takamichi that kisaki is the
true enemy
reaffirming takamichi's assumptions
something that baji realized when he
witnessed kisaki offering mikey
parchin's freedom
in exchange for the position as the
third division captain
he does not consider kisaki the third
division captain
saying that only parchin will be the
third division captain
bhaji says the six founding members of
tomens are his treasure and although he
was unable to fix tobin on his own mikey
has no reason to kill kazatura now
because bhaji died by his own hands
nearing death
bhaji tells takamichi that he reminds
him of shinachiro
and says that he is leaving mikey and
toman and the hands of takamichi to
which
takamichi starts bawling his eyes out
and crying telling baji not to die
which bhaji's last words were parchan
mitsuya
drakken maiki and kazutora
tomen's founding members are my treasure
i wanted to fix this on my own
but i just couldn't i died on my own
and that he would love to have some pay
young yakisoba with shifuyu for one last
time
but yeah i hope you all enjoyed my video
on who bhaji is if you want to see more
tokyo avengers videos like perhaps a
video on the entire valhalla incident or
maybe one about kazutoria then leave a
comment down below with what you'd like
to see
also if you do enjoy my content then
make sure you leave a like on the video
and hit that subscribe button
to make sure you can keep up to date
with the latest tokyo avengers spoilers
reviews and more
but for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and i'll see you all
in a bit
bye
[Music]
you